you
[Music]
I'm standing actually standing for love
he was the host for this talk
my name is dawn and today we are
fortunate to have storage experts from
Dell join us to give us a talk on pro
Vega Pro Vega is a open source system
that caters for both streaming and the
batch processing and without further ado
I will let you guys take away thank you
son
yep today we're going to talk about
previa
which is an open source product we had
people who started it with Dell EMC but
it's an Apache 2 or 2 license anyone can
participate in it
Oh we'll talk about what are the
motivations for building it and talk
about the design all right
my name is shriek on and followed by a
Tom Kyte chick and Andrew I'll be
talking about different aspects of the
port I'll start off with the motivation
of why we did it
and what's the motivation for doing this
and then that was followed by a little
bit more detailed design of how we
achieved some of the features that we
want to achieve all right first of all
so why did you build a bigger we wanted
to build an ideal storage system for
stream processing systems right you know
where it's trill or but it's flink or
whatever meant to the stream processor
that you choose how do we really build
an ideal storage system that works very
very well in the process what we did was
we want to build a stream as a
fundamental storage primitive just like
you have files and object and all those
things and block as the fundamental
storage primitives how can we build
stream as a phenomenal storage primitive
and I say stream it's like an
append-only log right how can we build
this as a fundamental storage primitive
and how can we built in a scalable
fashion so that that can become the
basis for not only stream process but
also other middle-way
which can build on top of it there was
the thinking about how is child about
this project so as you know any of the
database systems whether it is an Oracle
database or a key value store they
primarily use a log storage underneath
for several of their operations where
it's the application and for all those
purposes right but they're all
proprietary log systems right and built
for their own specific product our idea
was if you really take this as a
fundamental primitive and build it as a
scalable distributed system how can that
be used by other systems to build on top
of it so we want the world to look
something like that instead of everyone
building their own proprietary log
storage and we call that product Pro
Vega and we're going to talk details
about what the product is and what is it
but our ultimate goal is to build
something like this which is on the
right-hand side where you have crave
Iger which actually clears down to a
scale scale out system like a blob
storage for example in case of Fisher
right and then but it's a pops up engine
or the stream processor analytical
engines are a no sequel database or even
a search like elastic searches plunk can
be built on top of it and instead of the
same data getting stored over and over
in multiple places that was the idea and
then what are the sum of so if you want
to build something like that if you want
to have a scalable we need to give
certain guarantees so that other systems
that will build on top of it can really
take advantage of these guarantees and
some of the guarantees that we provide
is its durable of course it's elastic
and strict ordering and consistency
guarantees I think that's the most
important part and as we all know that's
the toughest part in any distributed
system is provide that today we're going
to talk about how we provide all those
things as part of previa
well it's more or less the same thing
all these features are what we're going
to pro we we plan to start with in
privity the problem is that a lot of
messaging system that have been built
before right and they are the ones which
are used for this purpose in the absence
of a really scalable durable consistent
lock system right you can say Kafka and
others kind of fill that space but
they're not built from that perspective
and if you know Kafka was started in
LinkedIn as a means for different people
to kind of say in the clickstream data
take the clickstream data it kind of
changed how the existing messaging
systems work in the sense of didn't
store the state of consumer that's what
made it much more useful for big data
systems but not really started off this
mechanism where we need to really build
a consistent stream storage system right
so we took a different approach from
that perspective in a way high level our
architecture looks something like this
now of course this shows in a single box
but it's completely scale our system
where the stream abstraction is very
simple you always happen at one end and
you can read from anywhere start from
somewhere and keep reading in sequence
when you first write we write into what
we call as a Tier one storage which is
fast and it is only used for durability
we generally don't read from Tier one
storage it's also cached and we general
read from the cache for real-time
applications but the same data is
steered into a long-term storage like a
blob storage device for example or HDFS
whatever it is right and then the data
is read from tier two or the cache most
of the time the tier one storage is
primarily meant for for in failure
scenarios to provide durability because
of that the Tier one storage is Right
friendly
we don't read from it other side and
we'll talk about the details of it but
but we replicate in Tier one storage and
act back immediately so that you get a
fast durable storage for Tier one and
then we take that into a more
high-throughput systems which are more
efficient not for small writes because
right friendly the Tier one is also very
friendly for small writes which is what
most of the storage systems have trouble
dealing with whether it is the blob
storage or HDFS ok so that's the whole
high-level thing let's get into private
funnel some of the fundamentals of
Praeger all right in Privia
extreme is made of segments the segment
is a fundamental even low level storage
primitives that we use and a segment is
nothing but a sequence of bytes that you
write into and then you act back such
durability stored all the time let's
think of it now extreme is made up of
several segments like this and when you
write typically give a routing key which
determines which segments your fit
segment you're writing to for that
specific routing key right so that's a
stream the thing is each of the segments
can be on a different box so you can
horizontally scale out this as much as
possible there is no limit on number of
streams number of segments or anything
like that you just spread across and
you're of course not and one of the
things which helps us is is very similar
to a lot of system that you have might
have seen here you write to a segment
and at one point of time you see in the
segment so that you can't write it to
write to it anymore right but this is a
very important concept at how we scale
and how we do different things and how
we provide different facilities this is
one of the important aspect to it now
stream elasticity let's assume you have
a stream with a single segment start
with you're writing to it and once you
punch it load increases obviously one
single segment can't handle it and then
what do we do we seal that segment and
split the routing keys between two other
segments you create two segments now
these two segments can be put on
different box in fact Rebecca does is
all based on some policies that you can
associate to the stream today those
policies are rated vegetate s coming in
both from in terms of number of times
and volume of the data coming in right
so it does this automatically for for
this segments right you can keep
spreading and spreading out the segments
on different boxes so let's see how does
the stream look like the x-axis is time
y-axis is the routing Keys just
normalized to 0 to 1 here initially we
start by the single segment stream right
and once at time T 0 we find that the
volume of load is too much so we split
the top of the roading keys to the top
segment in the bottom half to the bottom
segment and then time T when we find
that even the top of the routing keys
are getting hard so we gain split it
into two we seal it and splitting the
top half of the routing keys again into
two like that you can keep on splitting
right but what we also do is we also
merge when we see that the data is for
the routing case is cold right so this
is very important because for real-time
processing systems it kind of gives clue
for the processor store to scale based
on the number of segments if they choose
to do that right think of this if the
whole Amazon ordering system is one
single stream it's possible to do that
and think of a zip code as a routing key
right at this point of time and uswest
is very very hard to you laugh more and
more the range of parting keys for
stream here on the West Coast will be
very small whereas in Europe with night
it will be large and your process can
accordingly scale up and down so you'll
have a feedback mechanism from storage
to do that in fact for one of the stream
processor flink we're working on
automatically incorporating into our
interval product so we can do that on
the fly right
so the most important the key regions
are dynamically assigned the segments
depending upon volume if you take the
heat map of a of a stream it looks
something like this the light blue is
low volume of data coming in radius I so
at time 11:30 when it's become very red
it splits into two segments similarly on
the top you see a scale down even where
it merged two segments into one right so
at any point of time a stream can look
something like this right by the routing
keys which are neighboring routing Kings
as a split or merged as we go alright so
that is one of the fundamental things
how we scale right because we can once
we split we can put the segment's on
different boxes so we are not restricted
by the eye ops on a single box anything
like that it spread across okay so the
other thing also is that as I said from
Tier one we automatically cleared the
data into a tier two storage think of it
as Windows Azure storage in your case
could be HDFS but we provide the same
stream abstraction so that you can go
and read it for batch processing if you
wanted to do for old later right and as
I said for the real-time processing most
of the time the data is served from the
cache right so so some of the things the
goals that be set out in the first
screen that I showed and how we are
doing it
it's the unbounded stream data that's
because we move the data to tier two so
we can have an unbounded stream reader
real-time and historical as I said again
for real-time most of the data is served
from the cache it's very important and
also the splitting and merging helps for
the process to scale up and down because
keeping up with the steal speed at which
the data is coming at you is very
important real-time processing and you
can do batch processing because you can
access our streams of data even though
it is an object storage right or you can
directly go to the hobby store in access
to
but we provide the same thing so that
when you have a stream processor which
is capable of doing both straight
real-time and batch processing it can
take advantage of this storage system
elasticity of stream I think we talked
about it a lot
you know we split and merge
automatically for you so you don't have
to deal with it it's not based on a
statically partitioned system like some
ocean systems are because of that we
provide elasticity automatically out of
the box very armed to deal with it and
we also provide transactions and exactly
ones guarantees on top of this we're
going to talk about how we do that in
detail in the next slides but we do
provide those mechanisms on top of a
stream abstraction and finally we also
provide a distributed computing
primitive what we observe is lot of this
applications you need distributed
applications need some kind of
leadership election and they are
dependent on something like zookeeper
which they don't have to do with previa
because we provide the distributed
computing limited we're going to talk
about that also you know slides how we
provide that ok some of the things right
you know in our case I just want to
differentiate between statically
polishing systems in the space and and
previa since the whole key space is
assigned a single stream and the end
when you want more parallelism it
automatically splits into segments
whereas in a statically partition system
you have to deal with all that you have
to bring down your producers you have to
bring down your system and kind of do it
that way I mean last I check the event
hub also I had the same problem right
because it's statically partition when
you start a stream or specify how many
partitions but if you want to
repartition you become successful then
you're in trouble with those kind of
systems right in our case we just split
in put it on a different box and spread
out that same case with the read side of
it also the other thing I think which is
this is even more important is in terms
of how you
spread your data over time and out how
to automatically rebalance your segments
which we do because if any segments
become hot at any given point of time in
a statically partition system you're in
trouble either you slow down your
producers right which is it which is it
you don't want to do with those
messaging system exists because you want
to provide that buffer but if you slow
down your producers you're in trouble or
you over provision so that whenever you
think you're going to hit that peak
volume you provision to that so that you
will work well right in fact I worked in
Microsoft before it being used to use
Kafka and then these two have this
problem they would have a huge Kafka
cluster because bring is such a good
dinah'll data they're trouble dealing
with it will short bursts of big volume
and they had to have a big cluster take
care of that in our case though if it
gets hot we spread it across different
boxes so you are globally optimized for
all their ups in the cluster as opposed
to a local thing I think that's the
biggest advantage you get from using non
statically partition system like us like
Prairie go the other thing is stream
processors right how can stream process
because as I said we originally started
out with this idea that how can we build
the best storage system for stream
processors like like drill in your case
and and this kind of gives a picture of
that right you know there are several
producers which are producing on
different routing keys but we can split
it because each segment is a range of
partition keys right then your routing
keys see there you see the bigger width
there of segments and then now your
workers on the stream process side you
can attach one worker first segment for
example we can use different policies
but one example could be that and you
can change the number of workers based
on the number of segments you have which
is automatically done by kreega and then
because we provide this exactly ones
guarantees when you write if you use
Praeger sync
for a batch of some of the newer stream
process provide exactly ones gain for a
single job but if you use privet as the
sink for a series of jobs for a batch of
jobs for a pipeline of jobs you can
provide enter and exactly ones
guarantees right so that's that's one
more thing for stream process can take
advantage of this right the next thing
is you know today if you if you look at
it
most of the systems are built that you
know the data is ingested into some kind
of missing buffers event harbor or Kafka
and then ETL into a long-term storage
but what happens is if you have a
business model that your belt over it
could be a machine intelligence model
that you've built it works of the data
that is coming into Kafka which is
operational data in this case we have an
example of a wind turbine system which
is sending the data and this model works
off of data coming from Kafka and
decides whether it's return of turbine
or there's any problem a turbine and the
data then ETL into an HDFS system but as
always there will all be new business
logic battle models that you have
evolved and you want to test if the
models working better or not so
typically that you do with your older
data which exists somewhere else in HDFS
system in right against that and once
you find that logic is then changing to
the life system is where the trouble is
that you have to cook up things and make
lot of things to being networked but as
when you have the stream abstraction all
through right you know this business
model working on streams new one comes
because it can go and process the data
the older data it can go and process it
and find out it's working well and once
you're happy you can just turn off your
original business logic so that is one
of the advantages of treating everything
as a stream both for an old data and new
data that's coming in which is not what
you have because you don't have a system
which facilitates something like this
right another big change that that's
going on in the industry I want to give
this lifts example as a case for what's
going on in the analytics world and
distri is that people are strolling of
course even in this case the store in
Kafka the initial data comes into Kafka
then they pull the data and store it in
s3 because lift is on a SS most of the
time but if you look at it on the right
hand side most of the processing is
happening off of s3 right whether it's
higher and other things because object
systems are scalable and they're
available and you know and in some of
the cases like our object store is
geographically distributed with
consistency
against yours in that case you have
everything that you want from a pure
storage system for as a long-term
storage so the processing is happening
off of that but then you have link or
something working off of the Kafka data
to process data and data in some cases
or make decisions for real-time
applications and all that and this has
become more and more standard as opposed
to using something like HDFS at the same
time people do this because you don't
have the the messaging system of the
system which can take small writes be
able to process both real-time data and
batch data right once you have that
because now the newer stream process can
do both
because they treat batch as a special
case of stream where it's bounded by
start and end then something like cray
Vega will be very very helpful to do so
in short all the things that we have to
set out whether doing batch processing
or stream processing on the same system
whether they're reliable is scaleable
storing the system and whether it is
being able to give clue to the processor
as to when to scale when not a scale or
some of the things that we have set out
to as a promise for previa and I would
it right Tom now talk about how do we do
with with pre Vega the details
all right so I'm going to talk about the
fake client screen so the per Vega
client is a little bit different than
then you might be used to for for a
variety of reasons but the main one is
that when we say that per Vega is a
streaming platform we really mean that
it's a streaming platform and it's not a
messaging platform and so the server
Vega server actually doesn't understand
where event boundaries or messages or
any any higher-level construct is
dealing with a stream of bytes so it is
no more sophisticated than a UNIX pipe
or an HTTP socket it is no
interpretation of the data that's going
over it whatsoever so it is completely
up to the client the writer is putting
in bytes and is up to the client to
parse those out into individual messages
as it sees fit but to make that work for
a variety of platforms we need to offer
a bunch of guarantees so we have events
coming in from writers they'll be
multiple of them right into multiple
segments according to routing key the
Shrikant described and we're going to
end up fanning those out to different
readers and sometimes those will be
shared across spreading load across many
readers and sometimes it'll be but be
dedicated and they'll often be many
reader independent groups of readers
reading off the same stream but to make
that work we need we need to lock down
what our guarantees are and so we
guarantee is that when you perform a
right against per Vega is guaranteed to
be atomic the whole thing goes in or
none of it does
and it will always be delivered in order
on a per key basis this is actually
implicit in the fact that the that we're
dealing with segments and those segments
are are not interpreting the bytes if
you think about it you the graph that
Shrikant through of segment splitting
and merging you can draw a straight line
on any given routing key from one
segment to the next to the next to next
and within a segment we can't possibly
reorder or duplicate data because we're
not interpreting of boundaries between
one thing in the next so if you were to
reorder some bytes in there that's just
data corruption so that's how we
guarantee in order and it's how
and we have some some additional
semantics I'll get into of how we can
guarantee exactly once which is a very
important property that we have but
there's some things we don't guarantee
notably which is that we don't guarantee
ordering across routing keys and if you
think about this makes perfect sense
because if you're going to have multiple
readers and they're gonna be processing
the data in parallel and you say well
you know we're gonna partition this by
say a customer ID say that's our reading
key well we say okay well we're gonna
give customer ID you know Fred 2 to 1
reader and we're gonna give customer ID
Bob to a different reader well they're
processing data in parallel and they're
intentionally so so that you can you can
scale up and so of course there's not
going to be any ordering guarantees
between them so it's only when you sort
of explicitly lock down and say this is
a data for this customer ID must be
processed in sequence do you get that
guarantee to come into play and
similarly we don't explicitly guarantee
that that a it we're not like a sequel
database or anything like if you if you
have a read call it's gonna open a
socket and it's gonna give you data as
data becomes available we don't
guarantee that latency we don't don't
say that oh you're gonna get that data
within 5 milliseconds of it having been
written and that's a very important
property because we're going to take
advantage of that and some of the things
I'm going to show you later so one thing
we do is we maintain strong consistency
and that's a little bit tricky to do
because you can have failures so it can
happen is you have a worker here who's
sending in some data opens a connection
and start sending events over the wire
and as those events go in the connection
can fail at that point you'll notice we
have this counter up here that's at four
that's atomically incremented on every
single one of those those rights that
occurred and so when the worker
reconnects it can ask you know where'd I
leave off and the server can tell it oh
you left off at four and it can resume
from exactly that point so regardless of
whether or not you're sending a
continuous stream of bytes or you're
sending discrete events you can always
get a consistent picture of what
happened on both sides
so to do that we need to have that
notion of atomic compare and set we need
to be able to atomically pen data and
also have this metadata counter that we
can atomically update and that is in
fact a casts and that is i'm gonna get
into how we use that later on but it's
it is a very powerful permit and in fact
if you study sort of the theory and
consistency it is it is the strongest
form of primitive and you can build any
other model on top of it and in fact we
do which I'll get into so one thing we
do with it is we have this notion we
call a state synchronizer and a state
synchronizer is a little bit of a weird
thing to wrap your head around because
it's maybe not an api that you're used
to but essentially you have a log right
and you can use a user segment as a log
and it just writes transitions to that
log so it starts out with some initial
state and then it writes an update and
then another update and then after a
while you note oh okay well here's the
new state and right it writes a
compaction of all the updates so far and
then you can resume reading from that
point and you can maintain that
consistency using that same can parents
that mechanism I described so what that
looks like from a client perspective is
you have this append only log and you're
sending it updates each one conditional
on the fact that you've seen all the
previous updates so if another update
comes in and you haven't seen that
previous update due to a race condition
because on another server then your
update will fail and you'll find that
out immediately and you can refresh see
the previous update and try again
so that uses optimistic concurrency to
give you a consistency of a view of an
object on across the fleet of posts so
this opens up a lot of interesting
possibilities we use this a lot
internally we certainly use it I'm gonna
go into some of the ways we use it on
writers and readers but it's a really
useful parameter for building macro
services because it gives you a
replicated state machine that can be
shared across multiple machines so you
can use this to do host membership
leader election all those things because
it has it has guaranteed consistency
one of the things we do is we have
transactions now the notion of a
transaction is on a stream so it's not
on an individual segment so what you do
is you open is you open a transaction
and you can write as much data as you
want to it and it turns action can
contain many routing keys it can
encompass the entire stream be spread
across many hosts there's no bound on
how much data you write to it and
there's no bound on how long it can be
open but once you decide you've written
all the data you want to write you can
call commit and that commit will be
atomic and by atomic I mean that it will
be guaranteed that all the data will go
in or none of it will it will all be
contiguous on a per routing Key basis so
there won't be other things interleaved
with it and that it will it won't sort
of randomly disappear due to some sort
of failure in the meantime even if even
if there's sort of an adverse event the
it doesn't guarantee the same things we
don't guarantee all the time we don't
guarantee the the latency after which
commit has succeeded that someone will
be able to see that data we don't don't
bound that just as we don't on a normal
right and we don't Emilie similarly we
don't guarantee ordering across routing
keys when you're reading across routing
keys because that's by definition being
done in parallel so no additional
restrictions but it gives you some
pretty strong guarantees and the way
that works is that there's there's for
each segment in a stream there's a
corresponding transaction segment that's
it's created and there's this process we
call the controller which is sort of
acting as the manager of that
transaction it's it's a stateless
service it doesn't hold on to anything
in memory it and if one instance fails
it can be trivially replaced with
another but it's just a it's just a
point that can be used to to explicitly
coordinate that isn't the it isn't the
the writer who's writing to the
transaction it's important that be a
separate process but other than that
there's no there's no real requirement
there and so once it decides to commit
or abort it'll it'll propagate that
information
so from an individual stream perspective
you can think of it starting as having
say two segments then we'll create two
transaction segments as a sort of shadow
segment along each of them and then data
will be written to them and then it when
it gets committed the transaction
segments will get sealed and then a
metadata operation will occur where we
merge those transaction segments into
the main segment and since that's just a
metadata operation no data is actually
copied and the transaction becomes very
cheap and since you were writing to a
segment that's not really any different
than a real segment there's no sort of
per byte overhead or anything on an
ongoing basis associated with a
transaction there's obviously some
overhead associated with creating one
and and committing one but it's those
are metadata operations and should be
relatively cheap when I sort of zoom out
and show what this looks like from from
the wider perspective we've got worker
is going to call create transaction on
the controller the controller is going
to open in its metadata store which I'm
just going to talk about how that works
a a state which says this transaction is
open and then the worker is going to
proceed to write write data to that
transaction which is going to go to each
of the hosts and when it calls commit
the controller is going to be the one to
call commit on each of those hosts now
the important thing is that the worker
isn't the one who's contacting each of
those hosts and calling commit because
otherwise if the worker died midway
through then you would end up sort of
stuck in that transaction half committed
instead the controller is looking at
that state and saying okay well we are
in the state where we decided to commit
we're going to guarantee that we're
going forward from here so it's going to
call commit on each of the hosts and if
that controller dies or replaced with
another host who will see that state and
say oh okay well we need to go finish
committing that transaction so the
individual metadata changes are atomic
on each of the hosts and the changes to
the metadata here is atomic but on a
cross host basis there may be some time
lag there but that shouldn't matter
because the the separate hosts are
dealing with separate side
and there's not ordering guarantee
across them so all the hard guarantees
are still in place yes there can be the
yeah as I said we don't we all have any
guarantee of how soon after it is
written or in the case of transaction
after it's committed the data is
available to read so Chacon showed this
diagram and talking about scaling and
where we have a different multiple
segments and you know we're splitting
and merging and so on so on so we can
talk a little bit about how that works
we're on a worker is gonna be writing
data to a segment and similarly the
controller can say oh I'm gonna scale
that segment and it will seal it and
block any rights and then the worker
will contact the controller and say well
okay where's the new segment you that I
need to go to since that one was sealed
and it will get the answer and then it
can contact the appropriate host and
resume sending the data on it's worth
noting that it's important that this
controller doing the scaling is is is
the same is the same concept that was
doing the the transaction commit earlier
because you can end up needing to do do
do coordination between transaction
commits and scaling right like if you're
in the middle of this graph right and
you help in a transaction here you don't
want to end up committing it like end up
doing this scaling and trying to commit
simultaneously with the scaling event
right so we order the transaction commit
and the scale with respect to one
another either can go first right it's
perfectly fine for for the transaction
to open a scale to happen and scale the
finish and the transaction commit but as
long as you know once the transaction is
committing no scale events happen until
committed committed has been reached
so reader groups are an important
concept they're basically just a group
of readers that are collectively sharing
events out of a stream and we do that by
giving up segments and they similarly
coordinate with one another using that
state synchronizing mechanism I
described earlier so when you have a
bunch of readers they get a bunch of
events and one of the readers dies the
other readers will coordinate with each
other and say oh that reader is dead you
know we need to restrict the cévennes
and we'll end up rereading them and
distributing them across across
themselves so it's using that that exact
same state synchronizer mechanism
internally within the readers to manage
you know what needs to be processed and
who owns what data we also have a couple
other notions one of which is the notion
of checkpoints which I'm gonna go into
later which is essentially a mechanism
where readers can explicitly denote
where they are in a stream and then they
can can persist that state on the
application side and then resume from
that point later and for doing things
like that we we similarly use the the
state synchronizer to achieve that
strong consistency so for example we
have a concept called a stream cut and
what that is is you can sort of draw a
line through the stream in any place
that is that is consistent right so here
this string cut makes sense because
you're it's a it's a point in the stream
where you're going through segment 1 3 4
it's not for example going through both
segment 1 and segment 6 right that would
be that would be an inconsistent stream
type so so it's a it's a point in a
stream that you can logically resume
from because it makes sense that you
conceivably could have read to that
point right it's a collection of the
segments and the corresponding offsets
and those segments that you can pick up
and resume from when you want to so the
way checkpoints work is that they're
they're essentially just managing
drinka but they're managing it in a
coordinated way so you'll have a group
of readers that are reading from from
two different segments for example and
they'll be pulling data and they'll
coordinate with the state synchronizer
saying okay let's do a checkpoint now
and they'll see that update and then
react by saving their there in memory
state or whatever hasn't been persisted
in response to that and once they have
done that they can update that state
synchrony data that's needs to be
flushed et cetera and once that's been
done they can update that state
synchronized and say okay I'm done I'm
done
and then collectively produce a stream
cut that represents their collective
position at the time they receive that
notification and then if later they want
to resume from that point well they have
it they have that object and they can
pick up and roll back to that point and
resume from there later if they need to
having checkpoint across three does
rather than bother you two to reset an
application for example so flank is a
common user of per Vega and flink on an
ongoing basis persists every every five
minutes here is here is my in-memory
state and it writes it to its database
and it flushes downstream in the and it
coordinates so that the checkpoint in
the incoming and then if something you
know catastrophic happens like something
doesn't make sense it needs to restart
it can just reboot that job right from
there rather than processing from the
beginning if it is a small failure like
it knows exactly what data failed or was
inconsistent it can back up on an
individual reader basis but as a more
general failure recovery mode it will
just restart the whole job and because
it's doing that on an ongoing basis it's
not really losing much like if it if it
checkpoints every you know two minutes
and that's a continuous job that runs
all the time sort of backing up and
having to redo two minutes worth of of
work isn't isn't a significant loss
another concept that we have that works
very similarly is a notion called a
watermark and that works where there's
not a coordination amongst the readers
but there's also coordination amongst
writers so you can have a group of
writers that are collectively producing
events and those are being sent into
Perea and then they can say well you
know from my perspective we're finished
with everything before 7:00 p.m.
everything that ever occurred before
7:00 p.m. so we can just write that to a
state and once you collectively agreed
that okay all the data for 7:00 p.m. is
complete you can note that oh yeah
there's a there's this stream cut
corresponds to the point of of we are
now past 7:00 p.m. and you can note that
information and store that explicitly
into per Vega and then on the reader
side you can read those events and
receive that mark that was injected by
the writers saying yes 7:00 p.m. has
passed and you'll get you'll get that
notification and so the each reader will
know the point at which they will no
longer receive events prior to a given
time because of that coordination done
by the writers and collectively what
these these things lets you do is you
can have exactly once processing end to
end and this isn't some and this is
something we're not aware that of any
other system that does here I have an
example with flink but you know it's
just SAP Google for spark writing a sort
of system where you're reading streaming
data in from sensors and then you're
processing it storing it processing it
storing it processing and storing it and
the whole time you're guaranteed that
even this this job three levels away
from the starting point isn't going to
have duplicates or missing data or
anything else because you've had this
atomic consistency of transactions and
of you know making sure that the things
resume from the correct byte offsets the
whole time you won't end up with
duplicates and you won't end up with
with missing events even even when it is
changed and as far as I know for Vegas
unique in that capability but to explain
how all
this sort of internals work and how we
achieve all this metadata consistency
and and a precision and how we can do
this with low latency and high
throughput I'm gonna hand it off to
Andre thanks so Tom and Shrikant so far
they spoke about some features that
private offers so next we're gonna take
a look at some of the engineering that
goes behind the scenes which enable all
of those feature and make them happen I
want to start with a high-level view of
the private architecture all the
components and then I'm gonna do a dive
into the data path to explain how we
implement some of the most important
things that we've talked about so far so
one of the most important things that
Rebecca can run on any commodity server
so it doesn't require anything highly
performing to write on any of the box
shelf server there are three major
components improving on the brain of the
of the cluster is called a controller
the controller is simply manipulates
data which we store internally inside
probe Vega and performs leadership
connection within the cluster then we
have a number of segment stores which
handle the data path the segment store
managed stream segments and they like
this diagram shows they teared up
between tier 1 and tier 2 storage or
American without the upstream layers
knowing about we also have a client
which Tom talked about the client issues
what we call control control playing
requests to the controller such as
create a stream open a transaction
community transaction the controller
then orchestrates all of those things by
communicating working with the signal
stores but rebecca client communicates
directly with the signal stores to do
any sort of data path critical
operations like writing or reading it
doesn't have any other hop hops in the
middle
so let's let's look at how how we do
right so not on a very high level view
so we have a client we tried something
it gets into a second store which
buffers it internally then it writes it
to tier 1 which cannon gets replicated
and then it gets written to the cache
and act back to the client so the
important thing is that we only act an
event often we have durably written it
to our tier 1 and similarly we only make
it available for reading often we've
written literally so otherwise if
something crashes we don't think that
we've written it and we lost it or with
something downstream but then we don't
have it again similarly if we have a
second one it's gonna go and queue it
right replicate and then right after the
first event in the backend so a key
thing in our performances that reads our
students from rights well as you saw the
rights got written to Tier one lakh
storage but we never read from that Tier
one storage we only use that Tier one
for as an insurance policy in case we
crash and have to recover our stake we
serve all of our tail reads from the
cache and if something is lying the
cache then we're gonna go to our Tier
two object or file system to get it from
there so as a good scene we fetch it
from the cache and we only use Tier one
we only read from q1 to when we caused
it with the college of that cash so we
use this term called infinite stream so
other messaging systems just stored
their data locally on a local file
system and that bounds being all
together and you can write by the size
of that local file system but since we
automatically cleared data to our tier 2
and then we transparently provide a view
which unifies both to party or in tier 2
you can pretty much have a stream as big
as your cluster can accommodate so there
is virtually no limit other than
however on your cluster okay so that
that gave us a overview of the entire
Profeta architecture but next I'm going
to talk about a similar store which
handles the debate up they do that back
we also call it and in a plane so we
spoke a bit about the guarantees the
prevailing offers but prove a guy cannot
offer those guarantees unless the
segment store offers some of the same
guarantees so well the first thing is
durability we have to store data durably
before we act it or we make it a minimum
for reading otherwise we cannot even
talk about exactly once we have to
guarantee the data consistent which
means it has to be stored and and
replayed in the same order in which we
wrote it and we provide exactly ones
across both pain and historical rings
our performance is limited to only by
the hardware as I'm gonna talk in a few
slides we have an ingestion pipeline
which automatically optimizes for low
latency for small rights but also is
able to handle high throughput when the
workload demands it peregrines are
served from the cache which means they
are going to be visible by the reader as
soon as we have written them to our tier
1 and since historical reads are fetched
mostly from our tier 2 which we assume
is optimized for high throughput we are
just the pass through so we're just
going to offer the same tuple and it has
these are 4 of the features that the
signal store provides I'm not beat on
them in the next slides one by one but
I'm just going to briefly talk over them
so segments are informing match to
something called signal containers and
those similar computers are evenly
distribute across the cluster this
enables us to scale horizontally and not
by increasing the processing capacity of
a single machine we use two types of
storage tier one is a lock storage which
we use for ingestion and we use file or
object or anything else which is similar
to that for long-term storage
we have a dynamic interesting pipeline
which like I said optimizes for
efficient throughput based on the
ingestion patterns and one of the other
things which seems that saves us from
having to rely on an external metadata
store such as zookeeper
we are able to store metadata internally
inside our own segments so we are
self-sufficient for that matter so let's
talk a bit about steamy containers when
you define a cluster you define a number
of thermal containers that's the that's
the current state of things right now
but we have some work on the way to be
able to change the number in the future
dynamically with while the cluster is
still running each segment is mapped via
a hash function based on its name to a
container and when the containers are
uniformly distributed across the cluster
each thermal container is responsible
only with the work for the segment side
own so I don't really care about
segments map to other containers they
have to stick to a particular node
that's because in order to enable fast
processing of various operations they
have to keep track of certain State and
other data related to each segment so
having a round-robin approach would not
have been appropriate in this case so on
the same topic of horizontal scaling
let's look at how the controller which
is not pictured here does leadership in
action so if we have let's say a node
failure it seemed we have pre statement
stores and we have six containers so the
first one suppose it dies for whatever
reason becomes unavailable the
controller is going to detect that it's
going to say I need to go move container
one container for somewhere else
it still has segments store two and
Queen available so it's going to move
one and four to one of the other ones so
it pretty much does or rebalancing a
similar thing happens in the opposite
case so let's say we go from the right
to the left so we add a node in that
case it's going to choose two containers
from each while sorry one from each
single store and add it to the other one
so it's going to go into a rebalancing
so that's one of the reason why I say
that control is the brain because it
goes in monitors how the
thinners are distributed you make sure
make sure that they always available so
okay so prove a god in itself doesn't
store any data we don't have any content
which says we have to go stored in a
triplicate instead we have three types
of storage that we rely on which enable
us to do that first one is T no one is a
long storage which means we are append
only we it enforces a single writer
pattern and when you read you have to
real events in sequence you can really
go in read from a particular position in
open source Rebecca comes bomb with
Apache bookkeeper and disparate this is
pretty much everything that we ever need
from it for tier two like I said we need
a file or object storage or blob storage
or whatever one they are the minimum we
need for operations create read write
and in it we need to be able to create a
file beneath it we want to write and
read from it that enabled us to come up
with the three bindings and open source
for engineering first NFS and s3 API but
you can plug in anything you want we
have clearly defined contracts so you
can write a little bit of code and
you're gonna make it work with whatever
you want in addition in order to
implement the cache each segment store
node has a local non persistent key
value store and in non free source we
use Roxie beam which is a hockey player
storage with this spillover increasing
it and we back it by an SSD so you can
cache more than what your memory allows
you to the store in it okay so far we
talked about bindings so let's take a
little look at the ingestion pipeline
like I said this thing adapt a little
bit based on your ingesting patterns
it can optimize for latency if you don't
have that much load or you can optimize
for throughput if you have a lot of
things to ingest them so I'm gonna take
you through seven steps that it does and
I'm gonna show you how it does all of
that so meeting begins from the right
the client issues a new request I want
to append seal merge or whatever else to
modify our
that being gets transformed into an
operation in the semi store and gets a
little processing queue the order in
which these operations on this queue is
pretty much the final order of the
operations then we perform opportunistic
batching well as its meaning means we
pick up the operations from the queue
and as long as there are other
operations waiting in the queue we're
going to keep adding them and processing
them as much as we can but if there's
only one of them winning and there is
nothing else we're not going to do any
sort of waiting which isn't going to pit
and write to tier one so in this example
we have six operations one two three
four five and six one and two arrive at
the same time so they can bash together
three four five and six arrive later but
roughly around the same time three and
four are rather big so they get back
together before is really big so you
can't really film what on a particular
right so he gets split into two rights
so batch number two has operation three
and about half of operation four then
three has the rest of operation four and
five and six all of these rights can
send asynchronously to our Tier one so
which means we don't wait for the
previous one to complete before and the
next one gets sent and then when you get
an acknowledgment from Tijuana hey I've
written this and everything before this
right then we are free to first after
the client and we ask them in the order
in which they were received and then we
add them to our in memory structures
which means they are available for
reading and then after we have them in
memory okay well we have to get them out
of that tier 1 and into tier 2 and we
have to do this without any user
intervention so we have some automated
mechanisms inside the segment store
which based on some triggers either
based on how much data with what humi
latest or how much time has elapsed is
the last time we wrote we we take
operations we bash them together we
write up to tier 2 so let's look at two
different segments you have a.m. beam
and let's assume that is operation
actually writes so
I think you have for rights for segments
a and two for segment B and the
threshold for flushing is somewhere
wherever that line is now in this case
we have in not data that we've
accumulated from segment a so we can
make a large write to tier 2
like should concern we are very we're
optimizing for small writes
but most final object stories out there
are having difficulty processing small
rise which which means that in order for
us to take advantage of whenever we're
bound to in tier 2 we have to try to
aggregate more operations together so we
can have a larger right so we aggregate
smaller operations to bigger right into
the bigger writes and ship it together
to Pier 2 and write it like that segment
B doesn't have enough data so it needs
to wait a little bit longer or
unclicking - you're right if data after
we've written this to tier 2 and we know
it's been there we are free to release
all of these they are from our tier 1 so
we're going chunking that so we can make
room for more data to to be processed
ok so so far I've talked about how do we
write it up but let's see how we can
actually read that data some of the
previous two slides said that ok after
we run into tier 1 we aren't with memory
structures one of that is the reading
next and the cache
that's because the non-kill one is
pretty much fragmented it's written up
into a long log but we need to figure
out how we're going recompose that into
something that can be resembled as a as
a continuous segment so we have a remix
which has pointers offset pointers to
some to some data fragments the data
fragments themselves are not stored in
memory in heap they're stored off heap
in layer memory when our crystal truck
CB which can also spin it to disk if
necessary if we use too much of it
this approach also enables us to do very
quick segment mergers so when you do a
transaction commit like Tom said it's
pretty much a metadata operation we
don't have to do any i/o for that we
just have to flip a few pointers and say
ok we have communities when we can
enable this is that when you have two
segments in that you're working with
both of them going to have some caches
and some indexes in that case we just
have a redirect for the merge offset so
let's say you have seven
which was merged with Simon a at upset
one one zero zero one we just have a
redirects a for those for that absent
range just redirected somewhere else and
that way it seems that from having to do
any sort of expensive IO on the hot bath
which means our transaction our
transactions in provegan are relatively
cheap so you can have a lot of them at
the same time without having any sort of
extraneous overhead so as a summary
here's a little diagram about things are
put together so I mean just baths which
is at the top a request is commemorated
operation that get put to a queue then
we bash them together by the operation
processor making written to a Tier one
after that they get sent to memory
structures memory long metadata in a
real index and they are made available
for reading after that point in this at
the same time in the background we have
a Tier two writer which reads the
operations from the memory log and rest
them to tier two the reading --next
merges the data from memory or from the
which is thrown in the cache with
whatever stored in tier two and it
provides a unified view of the segment
based on wherever the data is without
the user having to worry worth where
where the migration has been okay the
last thing I want to talk about is I
said that we are mostly self-sufficient
in that we don't have to store metadata
anywhere else like a zookeeper or any
other external America stores we have a
number of different types of metadata we
have we have to keep track of that
number scope streams transactions
segments and write positions which
enable exactly once
on the right side typically this is how
much they are but mentioning we are
there are we are unbounded with how much
on this manner we can store because we
store it in segments which are bonded by
the size of the cluster the next few
slides I'm going to talk about how were
we able to store with metadata
internally and access it in an efficient
rather because that's actually the most
important thing okay the most basic
thing in in our Merida is something we
call action
it's each segment has an unbounded set
of 16 to 18 but 16 bytes to 8 byte key
value pairs why those numbers that's a
very complicated thing so let's just
leave it at 16 to 8 in here the or the
origin of these attributes was that we
had we need to have a way to enable
exactly one to the right side so the
writers had to store a minimal state for
each for each writer so in training
which was identified by a new ID or a
grid which was 16 bytes very convenient
had to keep track of how many invents in
hand written so far in order to do a
compare and set so that's how that that
was the original use of segment
attributes in addition we standard
values to do table segments which I'll
describe in the next in the next line so
attributes being like sixteen by point
wise weren't very useful we needed
something that we can store an arbitrary
key to an arbitrary value so based on
that we expose another primitive called
at a table statement which is naturally
a key value store backed by a previous
segment this enable that enables that
enables us to do update removals batch
updates removals and conditional
averaging removals and of course
conditional end and batch updates at the
same time so what did we do here we
pretty much implement the hash table
with a linked list use for for collision
resolution and we stored all of that
into the similar attributes in a
nutshell that when we did that we hash
the keys to 16 byte buckets using sha
156th and we since that is 16 bytes that
come there is very convenient to stick
into one of those attributes and just
talked about earlier the way we process
this is we write all of our changes
whether there are removals or updates
into the segment so we use it as a
transaction log then we have a
background indexer which pretty much
means that and storage the attributes
and attribute segments which are then
being used on the read side to get the
location of Keystone we cannot read them
so there's nothing too fancy in there
but this allows that allowed us to break
free of limitations that we found with
other external key value stores since we
can store a lot of these keys into into
a single segment and that can be stored
in a cluster we pretty much were
unbounded in our experiments we did the
let's say I will generate about a
hundred million keys and using sha-256 I
got about five or six collisions okay
let's say ten okay that's very that's
very reasonable and if you want to store
more you can just share the cross
multiple segments and solve that problem
well that was pretty much the everything
not to say feel free we are like 15
minutes left I'm sure you guys have a
lot of questions and in the meantime
feel free to go to one of our websites
or follow our blog or our github repo
and see what we're up to
[Applause]
so so the question has one when you have
spinning emerging all right that said
some repurposing out yes adding new keys
and you're having yes no so like God
said so when you have a similarity to do
the wit crate to new segment and then we
still the first one so anybody was still
right - the first one is what I say okay
I got I tell running us anymore and so
I'll go back from a controller what the
door says okay oh you have to go right
to this new segment so it's not until
writing that other segment so the first
one doesn't get passionate stays where
it is we'll have to move anything up so
segments once they're written they state
that we don't have to go in oh oh
trying them open and rewrite them up
there with some easy to do it defined
yes yeah so so when you seal the segment
that's an assigned to operation on the
server side it says no more rights can't
her do this and doing rights attempt
into going after that will receive an
error the error is gonna be internally
held by the client library - you know a
sexually treated as a redirect and
figure out where it needs to go now
right so if you're up
yeah in this case let's say let's say
great to to round he that hacks its 2.2
right so in first-year writing Sigma 0
you ready Freddy fender great Benz great
and then you get or you'll get that car
and you were drunk and you say okay well
I to write Sigma 2 now that's gonna
ready lunch and then it's going to get
another huge thing okay now and still to
now and it's gonna read Singapore so a
reader who's reading that writing key in
order is gonna read ii 0 than 2 then 4
so the order is preserved but you know
sequentially you also give a bunch of
examples of our flick as streaming
handsome disney investigator thick as
well are there any other streaming
engines that you're working closely with
pro maybe i'll fits nicely certainly
spark we have a connector also you know
those are those are sort of the big two
I mean Prague is not limited like its it
has a independent API that you can read
right from it so it's pretty easy to to
spin up new new applications and new
connectors back job yeah those are those
are two big stream management's we see
so is there a notion of truncation from
the beginning holy always deal with
retention yes yes there is we can
exactly that we can truncate anything
okay and the readers cursors are
independent it's always ever-increasing
cursors
yeah yeah so so readers are like if you
have a reader group
it'll be reading starting from a stream
and internally that stream cut is just a
map that contains a segment offset oh
yeah so you uh your current read off
Sega's relay due to the last stream cut
is that a good way to think about it no
it's it's absolutely so so if you have a
if you if you're a reader and you are
reading from segment four in your memory
there is a number of those literally the
byte offset where you are
segment four okay and if you take a
string cut that's just going to record
that byte offset in an object and you
can persist that somewhere if you want
to resume from that form if you you know
what and and that'll just keep going
incrementing up forever right so if
thing before lives for a very very long
time like that number will just keep
getting higher and higher but you know
it's a long so that's fine but if I you
say to chop off the first hundred
gigabytes of that then yeah so if you if
you say to this stream hey I want to
apply a retention policy where all the
data before this time T to just delete
we can use clear that and then if you
come to us with a with an offset and say
hey I want to resume from back here
we'll say sorry that data was deleted
right here like you'll get that error
and you mentioned that you want to need
from the cache not from the storage yes
what happens when you started in the
limits of cash and not the screaming job
and listen is a cool data processing job
it's just going over last years of data
we say how do you guys catch TV capacity
or do you mean great oh you mean the
capacity right yeah so nothing you Chris
talk about that's your example right
well yeah so next thing you read from
offset zero and you want to read a
hundred by it
we're actually gonna read about one or
two or three megabytes you can compare
it out who in that country because
chances are you're gonna wall everything
like how the weather so essentially you
go and read from the storage frontier -
we never read from tier one anything in
Tier one who's also in cash but we moved
it excuse me anything that is not in
tier two is also in cash but if it's in
tier 2 we can drop it and if you read
from it there's just a prefetch because
you know it's a stream you're you're
gonna read linearly like it's it's very
predictable and if you hit the limit or
we're just gonna pick some of the onions
once and you think one use them again
we're just gonna win them back
any reason that you were reading through
the tear was the tier one all that
through the cash all the time rather
than dating old reads directly be served
from your spear to storage yes well we
if I have a say a monthly job that comes
in by and then it'll trash and pollute
the cash rate so there is a regular
stuff happening and then you have a once
in a blue moon kind of thing it's funny
because here man we just occupies a few
hours ago so we haven't died because we
just haven't gotten to it yet but uh
because first of all if you want to read
and let's say more there you have to
know what the ordering of these segments
are second of all he you asked about
truncation right suppose you want to
truncate from this line with more from
let's say T to you know want to keep the
whole segment one in there because they
could be like hundreds of gigabytes in
there so well the way we store a segment
in here too is we we recognize two
chunks and we wrote them all word so if
you want to chunk it over then we can
just won't physically delete those
chunks but we need to figure out well
you know if you want to do reader to
compare to you have to know in which or
they want to read those chunks and also
because when we do a merging or
concatenation of segments that makes it
makes it even worse and we have a little
metadata object for each of these
segments which tells us okay this is the
order in which these chunks exist so we
are in the process of thinking of an
elegant way so we can provide a man who
wants to read directly from from the
underlying theory to how they can our
compromise information to them is it so
so answer a different part of the
question right your concern was like I
have this ongoing process that I want to
have low latency and keep up and then
here comes this big batch job and it's
going to just trash my couch well not
really because what's gonna happen is
you're gonna have a batch job yeah and
it's
gonna read and presently spatulas
reading old Dana so presumably it's cold
right and yes we're gonna pull in that
data from tier two and cash in but it's
a it's a to read ahead couch and your
batch job is presumably reading in order
so it's not like those reads were
unnecessary right there they were just
patched and made larger artificially but
that's not gonna like completely destroy
your cache because like you know you
read ahead one megabyte and that used to
megabyte of cash and then a little bit
later you read another megabyte but you
can throw the first one out because
you've done with it but maybe perfect
right so so ii really like like totally
destroy your cache you would have to be
doing like random reads from lots of
different segments which is just not the
nature of applications using the system
really they they very much go in order
also burn mine and these symbols are
distributed across the cluster so they
don't label on a single machine so
everything you're on the red line you
have one korean for reading from them
right those can be on different machines
so which are which everything in
parallel you're actually reading with
the throughput and the cache capacity of
three machines not one machine so your
ingress and egress trade are limited by
the capacity of your customer one
machine thanks is there any replication
on tier two storage if the containers go
down usually you create the dealer from
cancer so we assume that tier two is
self replicated so so if you're writing
to you know s3 for instance this DFS
great like we assume s3 is durable
because it acted yes when they started
to stay away from that business when we
just moved out between Tier one tier two
and by the way Tier one also has to be
replicated last one we chose a batch of
bookkeeper because it doesn't look that
for us we decided to stay away from that
business because it's a very messy one
so we decided to just focus on looking
down we wanna help if you have a certain
surge of number of readers for example
how do you handle that so um you can you
can have a surge in readers but the most
you can ever spin up and
usefully consume is one reason for
segment which is an important reason why
you want to lake house scaling policy
associated you scream to have you
haven't split into segments it's
appropriate but like if you have you
know a hundred segments on your stream
and then you spit up you know a thousand
readers well nine hundred of them are
going to sit there and do nothing but
you mean that there's a consumer wants
the ordering guarantee which is why yeah
actually
but what if yeah you don't want not a
guarantee we have an api to that we have
a we have a batch API which says
essentially I don't care about an
ordering guarantee just like look at
this graph and give me a reader that
segment reader for every single segment
here right so you can say you know you
can iterate over the segments and it
will give you it'll iterate over the
segment's create create readers so
you'll start here and you'll be
iterating over this graph you can create
a second zero reader or say one reader
second to reader and each of those will
read one segment beginning to end and
you can do them in parallel you can in
multiple machines or single machine does
it doesn't really matter and there
you're just reading a segment
continuously but you can ignore the the
ordering if you want you could process
segments that in parallel to therapy for
all for all weekend but yeah this effort
is a separate API because you know if
you're doing that you Pro like you
probably different sort of application
Wow it's all school thank you very much